Gene Menzies saved more than 400 dollars on this computer...
...and 150 dollars on this audio system.
When he bought his new TV, he got a 100-dollar gift certificate thrown in.
And he got all that by bargaining online.
When I buy online and do some of this bargaining, I'm probably saving...
...10 to 20 percent over what I find in the store.
Gene is one of more than 26,000 subscribers...
...Consumer Reports surveyed on buying electronics.
We found that people who bargained online...
...were just as successful as those who bargained inside the stores themselves.
Whether you're online or in a store,...
...people had the most success haggling for prices on TVs,...
...saving an average of 165 dollars,...
...and computer buyers saved an average of 105 dollars in another survey.
So, how do you get the prices down?
First, check online for the lowest price,...
...then print out what you found and take it to the store.
Or if you're bargaining online like Gene,...
...call the website's customer service number.
I'd say I found it at X Y Z store for this amount.
Can you beat it?
And if you're buying more than one item, Gene's got another bargaining trick.
I just said, "Look, I want two of these things. What can you do?"
And so they gave me 10 percent off.
Those negotiating techniques work in stores too,...
...and if you can't get the price down, ask for free accessories or free shipping.